le coeur à l'ouvragé et une marée
humaine rempli d'émotions parisiens
franciliens réunis de nouveau dans les
rues de la capitale en forme de chorales
[Applaudissements]
des français à l'unisson avec pour
instruments des pancartes de plus en
plus vindicative à l'encontre du
gouvernement
ce gouvernement est un gouvernement je
vais pas dire autoritaire mais
abusivement totalitaire on ne peut plus
le supporter c'est insupportable rentrés
dans une dynamique de tout contrôler par
principe pour pouvoir gérer à la place
de la vie elle même comment il faut se
comporter moi je suis contre il j'arrête
tout de suite mais tout de suite et
quand on voit cinq ans c'est long avec
un cac est né à mâcon c'est très long et
regarder tout ce qu'il est capable de
faire tout ce qu'il a tout ce qu'il a
enlevée de nos acquis sociaux de nos
droits il a entre nous nous traiter nous
insulter lui et ses ministres dits
responsables de capricieux on n'est pas
des enfants une cinquième semaine de
protestation et un discours qui semble
avoir évolué le passé ni terre
l'obligation vaccinale désormais au même
plan que d'autres actions controversées
prises lors du quinquennat d' emmanuel
macron une lutte de tous les instants
symbolisé par la présence d gilet jaune
ou encore d'adversaires politiques
gagner vive la liberté mais j'ai envie
de dire on fait le débat que macro n'a
pas voulu et on fait dans la rue
puisqu'il n'a pas voulu le faire il a
été un marche forcée à l'assemblée au
sénat en plus avec des gens qui sont pas
de pas bien résistant dans les
assemblées là bas rhin qui ont tendance
à obéir et puis un conseil social qui
s'est prononcé à toute vitesse qui comme
d'habitude s'est soumis mais il est où
le peuple souverain là dedans bah il est
là aujourd'hui on a des nouveaux
arrivants sur le marché de la colère et
comme nous gilet jaune ça fait depuis
deux ans et demi qu'on organisait
magnifique on a l'habitude du terrain
depuis bas depuis toutes ces années à
nous de les accueillir de faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent manifester dans de
bonnes conditions et de pour crier aussi
leur colère
l'actuel gouvernement qui maintient sa
ligne directrice envers et contre tous
les manifestants
mobilisation générale encore dans le
sud-est de la france au moins 47 mille
personnes ont défilé 6000 à marseille au
personnel soignant chauffeur de taxi ou
encore retraités syndiqués ont marché
ensemble rue de la république
les lieux de ralliement rempli de
symboles à l'image de toulousains
rassemblés dans le centre ville et à
quelques mètres du monument des
combattants de la haute garonne
[Musique]
c'est une loi que
que nous a imposé le pouvoir que nous
imposer monsieur macron après avoir
promis qu'il ne toucherait jamais au
liberté de circuler dans notre pays 217
actions recensées dans tout le
territoire avec une présence policière
des plus accrue
le gouvernement d' emmanuel macron temps
c est donc sous pression à quelques mois
de l'élection présidentielle
d'après un récent sondage mené par
yougov la cote de popularité du
président français est en baisse 28%
d'opinions favorables contre 31 pour
cent au mois de juillet